as to what is right and what is wrong
it's time to make up your own mind
you're simply going to have to rely
on yourself exhibit one
you cannot open your business if you own
a gym
in fact you risk arrest and loss of your
license no matter
how hard you try to comply with the
rules how hard you clean the facility
how much distance you put between gym
members but no stress
if you want a mass protest have at it
governor phil murphy exempted political
protests
from pandemic restrictions and joined
thousands
to protest go for it guys it's your time
but don't you dare go to work make sense
to you
but just today attila's gym owners made
up their own minds
as to what was right and used force to
open up their
gym that had been barricaded by the
state the consequences of their actions
are yet to be seen exhibit two
you cannot go to church synagogue or
mosque
in numbers of more than 50 but
multiply that number or bring 499
of your friends and all 500 of you
hit a movie theater down the street or
hell
all of you show up at a casino hang out
play blackjack hit the roulette wheel
throw some craps
so says the united states supreme
court yep there's a cap
on the number of people who can attend
religious
services at 50 but not for pro-profit
companies
like casinos and theaters that can have
500 and you can thank
justice john roberts for joining the
left
yet again and praised president trump's
appointee
neil gorsuch for the dissent that
reads quote there is no world
in which the constitution permits nevada
to favor
caesar's palace over calvary chapel
make sense to you exhibit three
you cannot protect federal courthouses
in this country
because if you do you're a violent
occupying force who brings terror
on peaceful protesters the ones who are
actually bombing
burning and destroying those courthouses
if you protect these halls of justice
you are nothing more than the enemy
bringing fear
to city streets so says oregon's
governor kate brown and portland's mayor
ted wheeler
forget that the leftists have injured
over 240 department of homeland security
officers
and intentionally blinded three
over more than 60 days of violent
upheaval
forget the section that 40 usc
section 1315 requires the department of
homeland security
to protect federal property forget that
neighbors
are frightened petrified and haven't
slept
in more than 60 days makes sense to you
exhibit four you cannot use
hydroxychloroquine
as a possible therapeutic for use in the
early stages of the coronavirus
because it can kill you and it's now
actually against the law in one state to
use it off label
the drug that has been used for 60 years
is now demonized marginalized and in
some states
banned for use as a treatment because
president donald trump dared to mention
it
in spite of the fact that scores of
front-line doctors and health care
workers
continuously recommend its benefits
along with zinc and a z-pack for use
both
prophylactically and in the early stages
of the virus
our own dr mark siegel prescribed it for
his dad and said it was a miracle cure
for him
and yet to others it must be outlawed
make sense to you exhibit five
dr fauci the head of the national
institute of health and infectious
diseases for
over 40 years who supposedly
understands infectious diseases has told
us that the people of the united states
don't need to be worried about covin
because it's not a major threat we don't
need to wear
masks then we need to wear masks
that it's okay to hook up on tinder
but plan to never shake hands again
that we shouldn't use hydroxychloroquine
because it's ineffective and calls
studies flawed
that show that it is effective as a
physician responsible for public health
should he not be receptive to all
observations made by doctors
on the front lines not just chase a
vaccine
but find ways to address symptoms and
complications
and arrest the progression of a viral
disease
does this make sense to you exhibit six
more than 100 police agencies have
backed out
of security for the milwaukee dnc after
their
civilian oversight commission denied
police the use of tear gas
and pepper spray to maintain crowd
control
during out of protests make sense to you
folks we are living in an upside down
world
where politics is the deciding factor
for
all things work play
religion safety and health
this is not a good place to be
truth and honesty are essential but when
clouded by the politics of lies
they are almost impossible to find
you have 93 days
if you like living like this you can get
more of the same
with that guy hiding in the basement
bunker joe it's time to take
america back and get it back on track
with president donald trump and that's
my open